good morning John at your suggestion I'm
headed to a big ball not actually for
clarity I'm home in Montana but my guess
is that a lot of people right now
wouldn't mind going on a bit of a road
trip one frozen in time a couple of
months ago a road trip I went on before
things got all hinky like just before
and I was going to upload this video
months ago but then other things
happened so I was driving from your
house to Albion College in Michigan
which took us basically right past an
attraction that you have shared with me
and that I've wanted to visit for about
a decade so since we could probably all
use a little change right now since
maybe we want to get away from our
places let's go on that trip this feels
like the part of the world where the
biggest ball of pain would be the
world's largest ball of paint is not
like anywhere in particular in fact
driving to it you get the distinct
impression that you are headed from
nowhere to nowhere and the really wild
thing is as you get closer and closer
and you see the little dot on your phone
saying you're nearly there it does not
feel like you're getting anywhere closer
to anything to the point where as we
approached I stopped believing it was
going to exist where the heck there's no
sign this is
this cannot be it come on ball paint
what world's largest ball of paint
that's the dice it's not all bad it's
not yep we drove to the world's largest
ball of paint and the world's largest
ball of paint was closed
sad sad just kidding
he turned the light on did he John the
world's largest ball of paint is very
very big over 40 years ago this guy had
his son paint a baseball and John this
is that baseball John while we're
talking to Michael about his big ball of
paint I cannot stop having this wild
destructive thought that I want nothing
more in the world than to cut this thing
in half I know it's a terrible thought I
don't want to destroy this perfect thing
but it's like standing on the edge of
cliff and wanting to step off I just
can't stop thinking it but luckily I
managed to avoid saying that I want to
slice this man's ball and half for long
enough that something amazing happens
John they just brought you up unprompted
I'm making a video okay who else he got
up there he's a big advocate of the
paint we all influenced each other of
course but I don't think you would have
had the thought that you might influence
this guy enough that he would bring you
up unprompted to me I kept telling him
what a big fan you are and I know you
can't go now but when this is all done
with John you need to go see Michael
Monica and I then painted the ball a
little bit but Michael told us not to
paint the whole thing because he had
heard that there were some people who
were gonna show up and suddenly they did
these three nice young people and I felt
a little like I was kind of no longer
inside of my story but inside of theirs
and that their road trip had this
extraordinarily minor character that was
me the guy who painted the other half of
the ball and then I was thinking that
you were in Michael's story and them in
mine and maybe the real main character
was the
and we were all just playing bit parts
revolving around it like a bunch of
minor satellites in a place that is
always there and is never nowhere in a
place like any other and unlike anywhere
else but then it flung me free and we
were on the road again the story's
shifting but the ball always there
waiting waiting for next time
John I'll see you on Tuesday